お釈迦様が勧める自分探しというタイトルでございまして
で サブタイトルになってるこの無我のアイデンティティというのは
ちょっとあまりにもかっこよすぎて
今日はできるだけ触れないようにと
であの できるだけ簡単なところから
まあお釈迦様の教えの紹介ということですから
あまり難しいことはお話をしないように努めます
で このストーリーはね
この前読み上げましたけど
でお釈迦様はこの悟りを開いても内打ちですね
あまりも日にち経ってなかった時なんですけど
ゆっくりやってくださいということになりました
で まあどこかでもう説法しながら行ったところで
どこかでお座りになっていて
そこでこの若者 30人ぐらいのね
グループに出会ったんですね
その 若者たちの話で まあバッダワンキヤって
この人々は一応まあかなりもう遊び好きな人々で
このまあ王家の人々なんですね
まあだからたくさんいろいろ国がありましたし
まあ王様王様という人々がいましたし
そちらの親戚っていうのはね
かなり大勢いましたからね
その若者なんですね そこでお祭りの日で
じゃあ遊びに行こうと思って
みんなこの 29 人は結婚していたんですね
それでまあ夫婦でもう遊びに行ったんだけど
一人には相手がいなかったんです
それでまあ 自分だけ一人で
もうなんとかどうかなということで
お金を払って まあ女の人をまあ一応買ったんですね
で 1日まあ一緒に遊びましょうと
そこで朝からまあまああっちこっち行って遊んだりして
まあものすごい大きい公園という公園ではなくて
もう林からね もうインドではね
まあ大きい国だからありますからね
そこら辺に遊びながらいて
まあちょっと疲れてね
あっちこっち休んだりする
その隙間で この買った女の人が
あの人々の全部の物やらね
まあ結構豊かな人々だからね
王家の人々だからね で
持っていたもうアクセサリーやら何だかんだをまとめて袋にして
この女の人が逃げちゃったんです
これ持っていった方が
その方がもっと儲かるぞと
だから目が覚めて 昼寝から目が覚めてみたら
もうこの女の人がいないんですね
全部物は盗まれている
それでこの林の中であっちこっち一生懸命探すんですね
この女はどこへ逃げたか
どこへ逃げたかとかね
いくら探しても この 30 人
なかなか見つからない
そこら辺の木の中でお釈迦様もまあ座って
まあ昼はね だいたい瞑想サマーディに入っていることもありましたからね
そこら辺で座っていたんです
それでお釈迦様に会って
でお釈迦様に聞いたんですね
まあそこら辺 女の人でも逃げているのを見たんですかと
で まあもしかすると お釈迦様は先に聞いた
あなた方は誰を探してるんですか？と聞いたら
まあ女を探してるんだと
お釈迦様は見たんでは見たんでしょうかと聞いたら
ちょっと待ってくださいと
君たちはね そんなこんな女を探すことよりも
自分のことを探すことの方がもっといいんじゃないかなという話なんですね
だからいきなりこのものを盗まれて混乱している人に自分探しと言っちゃったら
それは別にもうピンとこないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり自分たちも反省していたんですね
自分のことはもういい加減で
まあお金持ちの人々だから
随分無責任で昼寝したりしちゃうと
これは自分を守ったことにならないんですね
だからその若者たちはいくらかはもう完璧に女の人が悪いっていうわけじゃなくてね
やっぱり自分たちの不注意の原因で
自分たちは無責任でいい加減で
遊びにふけで まあ昼寝したい時は昼寝したりとかね
そんなことやったんだからこうなったんですから
自分を守ることは大事ではないかという考え方あったんですよ
だからいきなりお釈迦様の言葉はちゃんとピンと来たんですね
だから探すべきのは これは女の人ですか
自分のことですかと そういえば
やっぱり私たちはしっかりした方が良かったんじゃないかなと
という気持ちになったら
じゃあちょっと座れと
でお釈迦様はまたそこでその若者たちに説教するんですね
だから  お釈迦様のことを一応知っていたでしょうと思いますけどね
ですから同じ民族で まあ必ず叱られるだろうと思ったでしょうね
若者はなんてことをするんですか？とかね
一応あの その話を聞いたところで
その人々はまあ財産もなかったことも全部なくなったことで
まあ出家することになっちゃうんですね
出家して まあ悟りの道を歩むようになるんですね
そういうことから アッターナンガヴェーセイヤという自分を探しなさいということが出てくるんですね
だからその中から何が見えますかというと
やっぱり私たち人間というのは
誰でも自分を探すんじゃなくて
他人を探してるんですよ
自分のことは棚に上げて他人のことを探してるんですね
だからこの他人のことといって
そういうことなんですね
だから例えば まあいろんなことを探し求めている
どんな服はよろしいでしょうかとかね
どんな食べ物はよろしいでしょうかと
そういうのを他人を探すことなんです
結局は どんなことを勉強すればいいんですか？どんな仕事に就けばいいんですか？とかね
どんな地方で どんな家で住めばいいんでしょうかとかね
誰と付き合えばいいんですか？とかね
誰と付き合わない方がよろしいでしょうかとかね
そこで我々の人生はそういうことでいっぱいなんでしょう
朝から晩まで 生まれた時から死ぬまでやっているのは他人探しなんです
自分は何なのかという人
この質問だけ それだけは頭にはよぎっていかないんですね
自分が何すればいいかと
誰と話せばいいんですかと
どんな仕事をすればいいんですかと
どんな本を読めばいいんですかと
どこへ旅すればいいんですかと
例えばどこへ旅すればいいんですか？と聞くこと自体も
もう場所を探してるでしょ
どんな場所を面白いかと
どんな遊びすればいいんでしょうかと
一人でいる時でも まあどんなテレビ番組を見ればいいんでしょうかとかね
とにかく外何かを探している
その外で何かを探していることは
我々は 1分たりとも止まらないんですね
寝る時でも まあここでどんな布団で寝ればいいんでしょうかとかね
北はどこですか？とかね
もう北には枕入れませんだからね
死んじゃいます でも私は北分かりませんだけど
まあそれは冗談で言ったんだけど
とにかく どんな方位はよろしいでしょうかとかね
死神は今日は東西南北でどんな方向いるんでしょうかとかね
とにかく外から幸せを探す
それからなんで方位なんか気になるかというと
やっぱり外から自分に危険が来るんではないかとかね
玄関の向きが悪いんだと
だから家は不幸やというと
自分に対する不幸が外から入ってくるものだとと思っちゃうんですね
じゃあ では私たちの人生はそうやって外にものを探すことで精一杯でしょ
誰にしたってもね それやめたい人は誰もいません
ですから この大変なことを誰一人も自分探しはしないんです
政治家であろうが 一般の百姓さんであろうか
子供であろうか もう子供から大人まで
まあ寝たきりになって死にかけた時でも同じことでしょうね
どんな薬がいいんでしょうかとかね
本当にこの病院は大丈夫でしょうかとかね
外を探すんですよ 死ぬ瞬間でも
それで死ぬ時でも もうちょっと意識でもあったらね
まあ子供はどこへ行ったんでしょうか
孫はどこへ行ったんでしょうかとかね
それまた探しちゃうんですね
時々方々いるでしょうね
死ぬ時はやっぱり病院ではなくて
自分の家で布団の上で死にたいとかね
やっぱり外を探してるんですね
布団の上で死んじゃったら何かありますかね
いいことは 別になんかいいことっていうことはどうったことないでしょうね
家族に囲まれて 自分の布団でまあ死にたいとかね
それでなんでしょうかね
ですから 面白いことに
人間というのは徹底的に外で何かを探す
絶対しないのは自分を探すということ
それで私がこういうことを簡単単純なことを言いたいんです
この間 ちょっと電子メールの質問がありましたけど
まあもう怠けてまだ返事は出してないんですけど
忙しかったわけじゃなくて
あの その似てる質問というのは
まああまりにも聞いて聞いて聞いて
だからあまり面白くないんですね
あの返事出さなくちゃという気持ちも出てこなかったんですね
大体どういう内容かというと
いろいろまあ もう家のことやらいろんなことも朝から晩までやっていて
まあ時々もう腹が立ってくるんだと
腹が立たないようには努めてはいるんだけど
なんで私はこんなことばっかりやってやっているんでしょうかとかね
私はなんでそういうみんなに使われているんではないかとかね
そういうふうなことも思い浮かぶんだと
その時は決していい気持ちじゃありませんと
だからその時どうすればいいんでしょうかという質問でしたからね
似てる質問に答えて答えて答えても
みんな同じことを聞きたからね
まあ同じことを書きたくなかったんですから
まだ返事を出してないんですが
その問題考えてみましょう
なんで？ということ で
旦那さんが お茶入れてくれと
なんで自分がお茶を入れてあげなくちゃいけないんですかね
子供がお腹が空いたと
それで自分で聞いて なんで私がこの子供にご飯作ってあげなくちゃいけないんですか？と
正直にその質問に聞いてみてください
自分の心の中で なんでやらなきゃあかんかと
そこで全てのことについて同じ質問を出してみたいんですよ
子供でもね で 子供はよく聞くんだけど
君 学校に行きなさいと
子供は時々なんで学校に行かなくちゃあかん？と
それいい質問なんですよ
なんで学校に行かなくちゃいけないんですか？なんで勉強しなくちゃいけないんですか？なんで仕事をしなくちゃいけない
んですか？なんで結婚しなくちゃいけないんですか？
結婚したら子供を作らなきゃあかんですかね？なんで子供が勝手に生まれてきたら育てなくちゃあかんですかね
なんで旦那の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですかね
旦那の立場から見れば
なんで旦那さんが一生懸命働いてても
全部給料を家族にあげて家族を養わなくちゃいけないんですかね
そういう風に あの こんな馬鹿げた質問じゃないんですよ
すごい大事な質問なんです
ものすごい大事な質問なんです
だから我々人生でなさっているすべてのことについて
なんでそんなことをやらなくちゃあかんかと聞いてみてください
とことん  人に聞いたらね
怒られるかもしれませんしね
アホじゃないかと言われるかもしれませんだけど
で その場合 なんであなたにアホだと言われて言われなきゃあかんかと
それもなんでにすればいいんです？それはどういうことでしょうかね
一つの例を見ます 例えば赤ちゃんがいる
赤ちゃんが泣く そこでお腹が空いているということで
だから母親がなんで私は赤ちゃんにおっぱいあげなくちゃあかんですかと
誰もそんなこと聞かないでしょう
聞くべきなんです なんで私が赤ちゃんにおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんですかと
なんでしょうかね それでいちいち
これは例一つだけでね
いちいち辿り分けてください
それでいろんな答えがあるんですね
子供が泣いてるんだからと
子供にやっぱりおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんだ
いけないんだと 子供は成長しないんだからと
ということ じゃあなんで子供は成長しなくちゃいかないんですかね
またそこでなんでっていうことは成り立つんですよ
それであなた母親でしょ？母親は子供を育てるのは育てるのは当たり前やと
なんで母親が子供を育てなくちゃいけないんですかね
それも聞かなくちゃあかないんです
そうやってとことん もうどこまででも
どんな答えが来ても そちらになぜということは出しちゃえばいいんです
当たり前 当たり前というのはとんでもない危険なんです
我々はまあ 母親だから子供を育てるのは当たり前だと
そうすると何の疑問もなくやってしまっちゃいますけど
じゃあ問題は解決していますかね
解決してないと思いますね
だから 例えば母親がなんでおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんですか？いや
おっぱいあげないから子供は死んじゃうんだと
じゃあなんで子供が死んじゃうのは悪いんですかと
なんで悪いんですかね
だから全部私は 答え出したらいけませんと思いますけど
それ皆様方 やっぱり真面目にその質問をいちいちいちいち聞いてみた方がいいんです
だからみんなも時々は聞くんだけど
その質問 だから私でも同じ質問出てくるんだからね
ちょっと甘すぎなんですね
例えば子供の面倒だったら必要
まあもうそれは全然文句はないんだと
で 旦那がうるさくて なんで旦那の面倒見なくちゃいけないんですかと
それだけ私に文句言って
じゃあ子供のこと ああ別にそれはまあ母親だから自由にやりますよと
あれはちょっとおかしいんですよ
だから子供の面倒だったら見てあげるんだけど
旦那の面倒は見たくないんだとかね
ではなくて 平等で全部みんなに何でと入れた方がいいんですね
あるいは旦那の面倒は見たいんだけど
旦那のお母さんの面倒は見たくないんだと
それはちょっと不平等ですよ
よくないんですね 両方にする
なんで旦那のお母さんの面倒を見なくちゃいけないんです
なんで旦那の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですかと
そうやって聞いてほしいんですね
それでさらにそれはもう進めていって
なんで自分が服を着なくちゃいけないんですかね？なんで自分がお化粧しなくちゃいけないんですかね？なんで自分がご飯食べなくちゃいけないんですかね
なんででしょうかね なんで寝なくちゃいけないんですかね？なんで起きなくちゃいけないんですかね
なんで顔を洗わなくちゃいけないんですかね
なんででしょうかね そうやって我々はする
いかなることについても
なんでそういうことをやらなくてはならないんですかと
何か理由でもありますかと
納得いける 自分に聞いてみてください
自分が毎日ご飯召し上がっていらっしゃるでしょうに
じゃあなんでですかね？何か納得いく理由でもありますかね
なんでご飯食べるんでしょうかね
私は馬鹿だと思ってるでしょうに
そんなことは当たり前ではないかと
当たり前じゃないんです
それでこういうことになるんです
そういう質問を追求していっちゃうと
みんなある同じ答えに来るんですよ
なんで旦那の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですか？という質問がいちいちいちいち聞いて聞いてみると
ある答えに出会うんですよ
そこで なんで私はお化粧してご飯食べてきれいな服を着なくちゃいけないんですか？と自分のことを聞いてみると
またある答えに出会うんです
ぶつかるんです 不思議なことは
なんで旦那の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですか？なんで国の法律を守らなくちゃいけないんですか？なんで隣の人とは仲良くしなくちゃいけないんですか？なんで自分の
子供はしっかり育てなくちゃいけないんですか？という全く関係のないものなんですけど
答えが同じなんです 調べてみてください
調べてみてみたら 一つの答えなんです
すべてのものに出てくるのは
例えばここから帰るときはバスがありますけど
バスに乗る それで自分が立っていく
なんで私がこのバスに乗って立っていかなくちゃいけないんですかと自分に聞いてみてください
その質問は次から次へと質問してしていくと
ある答えに出会うんですよ
これ以上はいかないんです
それが同じなんですよ
なんで子供におっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんですか？という質問の答えと同じ答えに不思議なことに
だからこれも皆様の宿題だからね
で どうしようもないんですけど
一旦どうでしょうか いかがでしょうかね
それは調べてみたら 同じ答えにたどりますかと
あるいはたくさんいろんな答えが出てくるんですかと
じゃあバスに乗っている
自分が立っていく なんで自分が立っていなくちゃいけないんですかね
席が空いてないでしょ
席が空いてないんだから
席が空いてなくたって
なんでそれでも自分が立っていなくちゃいけないんですかね
人にあんたちょっとどきなさいとあんたどきなさいと言って座ればいいでしょうね
じゃあ言ってみてください
今日は座ってる方 誰でもいいんです
どきなさいと 老人は置いておいてね
老人と体の不自由な方々は置いておいて聞いてみてください
必ずと立ちますよ 立て席を上げます
もらいます 必ずも ちょっとどいてくださいと言ってみて
ないと思うの？やってみなきゃわからないでしょ
やっぱり必ずもう何のことなく
その方がちょっと変な顔をして立ちますよ
なぜかというと 生まれて初めての質問だから
なんであなたに席をあげなくちゃいけないんですか？って
そんな喧嘩すること頭の中にないんですよ
積み込まれてないで 一度もなかったことだから
だから必ず立ちます それは私には 100パーセントもう確信があります
立ってくださいって言ったら
友達っていうか その人を上下見るかもしれない
あなたですよと 立ってくださいと言ったら必ず立ちますよ
立っても何が起きるか
起きてくるのかわからないんですけどね
そこで自分が何のことなく平気で座ればいいんです
それでもその人はやっぱり喧嘩を売ってこないと思いますよ
というのは一度もなかったことだからね
自分の人生では だから皆様方は決してバスに乗っても立っていく必要ないんです
そうやって 立ちなさいよと言って
座席をね 空けてもらっちゃえばいいんですけどね
で 問題はなんで皆様方はそういうことをしないんですかね？なんででしょうかね
しないでしょ いくら私が言ってもやってくださいと今頼んだのに
決してやらないでしょ？なんでしないんですかね
だからそこで次の問題が生まれるんです
いとも簡単に座っていける
いけますよ いとも簡単に
でもやらない 立っている
なんででしょうかね それにまたいろいろ答えあるでしょ
そんなものは行儀が悪い
ね みっともない 恥ずかしい
他人に非難される 軽視されるでしょ
頭がおかしいと思うでしょ
周りの人々は この人は変だと
頭おかしい やべえと思うでしょうに
そんなことやったら それがなんで悪いんですかね
そう思ったっても 他人がね
このおばあさんがなんか頭がおかしい
この男の人 なんかなんか変だ
ちょっとやばいと思ったっても
どうってことないでしょうに
行儀が悪い人やと失礼な人やとかね
しきたりも知らない人やと思われても構いませんでしょ
でも なんで我々はそう思われて欲しくないんでしょうかね
自分にとってもあれはえらい
なんかプライド傷つくでしょ
だから自分が壊されます
答えが なんでみっともない
なんて情けない自分かですかと
みんなに嫌われて 批判されて
バカにされて 頭が狂ってるというふうに思われて
やばい人間だと思われて
何のことかと 自分ってなんで情けないかと思うんですよ
同じ答え 何でお母ちゃんにおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんですかね
母親が もしあげなかったらどうなるんですかね
それは私は産んだんだけど
おっぱいはあげたくないんですよと
だったら哺乳瓶いや あげたくないんですよと
それほどやりたい人がいれば
勝手にやってくださいと言ったならば
その母親に対して何言われるんですかね
何言われるんです？社会が
恐ろしい女やと 犬猫さえも自分が産んだ子供の面倒を見るんではないかと
あんたはもうそれよりも以下やと
あるいはあんた精神的におかしいんだと
病院に行かなくちゃいけないんだと
言って社会から叩かれます
非難されます 追い出されます
そうすると自分がものすごくみっともないと虚しくて嫌で
なんでみっともない自分かと思うでしょ
だから同じですね 答えが
バスに立っていて あんた立ってくださいと言わないこともそれで
なんでお母ちゃんに赤ちゃんにね
おっぱいあげなくちゃあかんかということも同じ答えなんですよ
じゃあ旦那のことを考えてみてください
じゃあなんで旦那の面倒見なくちゃいけないんですか？と
もし旦那が起きても食事しておかないとかね
お風呂も用意しておかないとかね
服も全然アイロンもかけておかないとか
洗ってもおかないとかね
ご飯作って自分勝手にもう食べるんであって
もう旦那がいるかいないか全く気にしないんだったらね
それだけで大変なことになるでしょ
それで旦那の親戚やら自分のお母さんたちやらね
みんな来て あんた何者かと
何やってるんですかと
自分を産んだ母親さえも自分を非難する
そんな風に育てた覚えがないんだと
なんで結婚したならば家の仕事ぐらいしないんですかとという社会の人々は
あなたがおかしいやと
頭が悪いんだと 病気だと
狂ってるんだと言って精神科に行きなさいと言われる
それで自分というのはなんで情けない
虚しくて苦しくて 生きる意味もない人間かと自分で思うんですよ
だから旦那の面倒を見るんです
なんで我々日本にいる間はね
日本の法律守らなくちゃあかんでしょうね
なんでそれ守らなくちゃいけないんですかね
好き勝手に法律を破ったりね
例えば信号赤なのに平気で渡ったりする
大体運転さんが気をつけているんだったら
殺す殺させませんだけど
みんなブレーキはかけますけど
だからといって平気で渡らないでしょ
法律は破らないんですね
平気で法律を破ったりすると
例えばもう買い物に店に行って
必要なものは全部カゴに入れて
お金払わないで出て行く
それで喧嘩する なんでお金を払わなくちゃいけないんですかね
とかね いや 払いませんよと
払う必要ない 喧嘩したらどうなるんですかね
それで法律破ってるでしょうに
それでみんなね この人はおかしいんだと
警察も呼んで で 警察にもなんであなた方はね
私はお金払いなさいって言うんですかね
払う必要ないんだと そうすると警察も困るで
そんなこと言ったっても法律は法律だからお金払いなさいよと
冗談じゃないよと 払いませんと言っても
警察もこの人は裁判にかけるのはちょっとおかしいんだと
やっぱり病院に連れて行きましょうということになるでしょうね
そうすると 自分というのはなんで情けないかという答えに来るんです
だからあの質問 なんで？という質問
どんなことに聞いても答えが一つ
わかりますかね その 私が言いたがってるポイントは
答えが一つ なんで子供は勉強しなくちゃあかんかといったら答えが一つ
だから面白く なんで例えば子供がお母さんに何でお母さん学校に行かなくちゃいけないんですか？と
それはね 私はこの掃除しているでしょ
その理由だよと 今床を掃除機かけてますからね
その理由と同じだよと言ったら同じですよ
お母さんが掃除機をかけている
それで子供がもう朝もう学校に行きたくない
なんで学校に行かなくちゃいけないんですか？と聞いたら同じ答えです
私は掃除かけてる知ってますか？と
その同じ理由だよと それだけ言ったらわからないんですけど
本当は同じ理由なんです
なんで掃除かけてるかというと
やっぱり同じこと 汚いんだから清潔にしなくちゃいけないんだからでしょ
なんで清潔にしなくちゃいけないんですかね
汚くてもいいんじゃないんですかね
そうすると自分が何者かと生きてる人間かとみんなに非難されるでしょうに
怠け者やと頭が悪いんだと
仕来りも何も知りません
知らない人間やとどうにもならないんで
みんな嫌を嫌がって逃げちゃうんです
いや あの人とはもう付き合いたくない
部屋 家の掃除さえもしないんだから
あの奥さんは頭がおかしいとなるでしょ
結局は だから同じこと
それと なんで子供は学校に行かなくちゃ
学校に行かないで ただ生まれたまんまで大きくなっちゃったら
もう猿と大した変わりはないでしょうね
で 仕事もない みんな相手にしてくれない
友達もいない そうすると
なんで私は生きてきたんですか？と大人になったら考えちゃうんですよ
だからすごくみっともなくて
虚しくて 大変な苦しみを感じる
だからなんです やっているのは
ですから このなんで なんで？っていう質問は本当に聞いてみた方がよろしい
もう答え出しましたから
何のお皆様は今 何の結果もなくなりますけど
本当は調べた 調べてください
これから これ真面目な質問なんですよ
いわゆるどこを行っても自分に関わってくるということ
どこを行っても最後に自分に回ってくる
時々 特に女性の方の場合はね
もう自分が一生懸命もう子供を育てやら
家庭を守ることやら一生懸命やっていて
もう今はつまらないんだと
なんとか文句言ったりする時もあるでしょうしね
そこで自分たちが一生懸命他人のために尽くしたんだと
尽くしたのに 今こんな結果だよと今文句言うんでしょうに
あれはちゃんと自己探求してないだからなんです
他人のために尽くしたわけじゃないんですよ
だから この私が今説明した通りに
なんで？という質問を持っていくと
すべて自分のためにやっているんだということは発見できるんです
そうするとがっかりしませんよ
旦那が浮気していても
あの人のためにここまで私は尽くしていたのに
いろいろもうお金もちゃんと節約して借金もしていたのに
それも全部払って一生懸命やったのに
もう今はもういくらかもう経済状況が良くなってくると
もう今は浮気始めているんだと
なんで私は不幸な人間かと
で そんなことはやっぱり悩む
でしょうに だから初めからも
我々は生まれた時から死ぬまで
結局は自分のためにやっているんですよ
そういう今やっていることは
一つでもやらなかったならば
自分というものが壊れてしまうんですね
勉強しなかったら 家の面倒を見なかったら
仕事を真面目にしなかったら
友達関係を真面目にしなかったら
法律をちゃんと真面目に守っていなかったならば
自分というそのものが壊れてしまうんですよ
だから結局は 私たちは自分というものを守っているんです
おかしいことは それには気がつかない
他人のために頑張っているんだと
日本の国民のために政治をやっているんだと政治家が言う
家族のために頑張っているんだとお母さんが言う
家族のために一生懸命真面目に仕事をしているんだと旦那が言う
お母さんが怒るんだから
父親がもう何て言いますか
怒鳴るんだから 真面目に勉強しているんだと
嫌な勉強は苦労してやってあげているんではないかと子どもが思う
学校の先生も この子どもたちのために必死になって
神経質になるまで イカレになるまで苦労して頑張っているのではないかと思う
みんな嘘 国民のために頑張っている政治家もいないし
家族のために自分を全く無視して献身的に行動する奥さんもいないし
だから人間っていうのは
やっぱりあれは自分の充実感のために
自分を肯定するために
自我を壊れて粉々になって消えないために
自我を正当化するために
私って偉いと という気持ちですよ
簡単に言えば なかなかやってるんだと
という この気持ちのためにやっているんですよ
なかなか頑張っているんだと
そこで あの そこまで理解できると思いますけど
ちょっと考え...皆さんは今まで考えたことがないものですよ
これが これは人間はあまり考えないんです
お釈迦様以外は だから単純に聞けるんだからって単純じゃないんです
悩んだり 困ったり がっかりしたり
失望したりすると すぐ見てください
あまりにも自分が自分をわがままというのは失礼な言葉かもしれませんだけど
自分のためにやっていたものなんです
そこでちょっとした葛藤というか
矛盾が生まれているんですね
自分のためにやっているのに
他人のためにやっていると勘違いする
そこはおかしいんです
子供が幸せになればそれで十分だと
私は子供のためにやっているんだと
社会のためにやっているんだと
家族のために頑張っているんだと
自分のことをどうでもいいんだと
と思うところが矛盾なんです
で そこで我々はちょっと道を逸れちゃうんですね
だから人のためにやっているんだ
人のためにやっているんだと思ってやっているんですが
それは決して人のためじゃないんだから
このやっていることはうまくいかないんですよ
だから 人生の中でいろんなトラブルが起きてくるんですよ
国民のために自分の命かけて頑張るんだと
私はしょっちゅうテレビで聞いていますよ
政治家の方々は 死んだ人は一人もいないんですよ
国民のために そこほど
それほど真面目なんですけど
しょっちゅうワイロ取ったとか
なんか不正なことをしたこと
すぐバレちゃうしね 何なのかと
政治生命を賭けていると
賭けるとかね 一人もいないんだけど
賭けた人 政治家の方々はわかりやすいんで
堂々ともう 30 分でバラの嘘を言うんだからね
笑い 我々の嘘っていうのは
大体もう何年でもね バレないようにすることできますけどね
政治家の嘘っていうのは言ってもすぐもうバレてるんです
もう嘘やと  だから例としては大変分かりやすい例なんですけどね
まあね で そこでいろいろ矛盾が生まれてくる
だから私たちは あの人も信頼できない
この人を信頼できないと文句言うでしょ
旦那も信頼できない 政治家も信頼できないとかね
そういう文句を言うことになってしまっちゃうんですね
信頼した自分がもともと悪いんだからね
だからその人々は別に私たちのために自分の生命をかけて頑張っているわけじゃないんですよ
あれ 自分のためにやっていることだからね
だからぐるぐると考え方が変わるのは当たり前で
旦那さんが一生懸命家族のために仕事をして
もう家族の収入を入れているんだけど
もっと気に入っている若い女の人に出会ったら
やっぱりそちらに行っちゃいますよ
なんであなたにがっかりしましたと言ったっても
あなたのことを信頼していたのにと信頼した自分が悪いんです
だから結局は自分のことを信頼できないんですよ
いや 奥さんたちがもう不倫なんかしないかというと
そうでないでしょうに
気に入ってる人 あ 気に入った
かっこいいやと思ったら
すぐずるずると行ってしまっちゃうでしょうに
だからどちらでも信頼できませんよ
子供でも誰でも なんで子供はずっと父親に母親にずっとついているんですかと
あれは遺伝的にものすごい親子の関係は絶対的だから
そうじゃないんです 自分のためなんですよ
自分のため 例えば 母親が怒鳴ったりすると父親がかばってくるならば
母親が怒ったら何のことはない
ずるずるとお父さんの方に行く
子供たちがお父さん お父さんがすごく怒ってザンザン言う時は
お母さんがまあまあまあいいわいいわと何とか言うならば
ずるずるずるそちらに行くと
だから子供の愛情でもそんなもんですよ
だから我々は人生の中でよくがっかりもするし
失望感も生まれるし もうやる気も失っちゃうし
いろいろありますよ 時々ね
まあ今最近あんまり聞こえませんだけどね
もう女性の方々は旦那さんが退職するまで待っていて
55歳であろう60歳にまで待ってて
じゃあ離婚しますと で
勝手に離婚して帰っちゃうと
あの人はもういきなり家に戻って
生まれてから初めて家に戻った時なんですよ
もう学校から会社に行って
それからずっと外の人生で何も知りません
家の中のこと それからどうやって生きていられますかね
平気で捨てられますね
まあまあ それでお互いにいろいろそういうふうないろんな問題の中で生まれてくる
結局自分のことしか見てないと
で  55歳で離婚にしようと思う奥さんも
今まであなたのために尽くしてきたんだよという考え方が間違いなんですよ
それ嫌だったら なんで結婚して 3ヶ月とかで離婚しなかったんですかね
だから自分が得する場合は得したい放題得して
もうこれからはもう邪魔者やと
というところで逃げるだけでしょうに
だから 残酷ということじゃないんですよ
だから残酷 旦那から見れば残酷かもしれません
そういう目で見れば そういうことじゃないんですよ
やっぱりみんな自分のことしか考えてないんですね
そこら辺に我々には知恵を与えてくれるのは
お釈迦様のこの自分探しなんですよ
だったら正直に自分を探せと
この偽善はやめなさい
インチキと偽善 これ 偽善的な生き方をしているんだから
世の中でトラブルばっかり
裏切られた気持ちにもなる
やられた気持ちにもなる
騙された気持ちにもなる
使われているんだという気持ちにもなる
それは偽善だからなんですよ
もともと だから私にメール入れた方についても
本当にズバリと答えがあるんだけど
あれは失礼だから言えないだけでね
嫌だったらやめなさいよと
それだけな答えは なんでいつでも人のために一生懸命
慈しみの瞑想をしながら
私はもう怒らないように一生懸命頑張ってるんだけど
時々もうなんで私はそんなことをやらなくちゃあかんかっていう風に
もう腹が立ったりもしますよ
どうすればいいんですか？って私に聞くんだけど
嫌だったらやめればいいでしょうに
だから答えそれだけなんです
嫌だったらやめなさい
なんでやめないんですかね
やっぱりそこに自己愛があるんだからでしょ
自己愛があるんだけど
それは否定する いえ 私は自己愛じゃないんだ
他人のために尽くしている立派な人やと
善人だと その偽善が世の中で人間の苦しみを作っているんです
だからちょっと心変えるだけなんですよ
じゃあ仏教を聞いたんだからって
これから仏教の方々はみんな他人のために尽くすんですか？それはとんでもない話なんです
やらない 仏教を勉強したっても
自分のために頑張るんです
で 仏教を勉強している人としない人の差が
しない人が偽善で騙されているんです
他人のために尽くしてるんだと
で 仏教の人は いえ これは他人のためとか何とかではなくて
私が嫌やと やらなかったらね
自分が不幸になるんだと
自分のためにやってるんだとしっかりしているんです
それで人生の舵はうまく操縦できるんですよ
偽善だったらできません
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
この心によるこの偽善のこの膜だけ破ってみなさいと
別にそれでもって世界で革命を起こすとか
そんなことは何もないんですよ
ほとんどトラブルは消えますよ
がっかりすることもなくなっちゃうし
まあ失望もなくなっちゃうし
まあそれぞれみんなそれぞれ自分の幸せのために生きていることになるんです
子供が暴力を振るって家出したっても
親があまり悩まない どうせ私は私のために子育てしたんであって
しなかったらみんなにいろいろ言われるしね
また可愛かったしね 楽しかったし
それは私にとっては良かったことで
今は可愛くもないし 恐ろしいし
殺される可能性もあるし
そいつもやっぱり私の子だって言ったっても
そちらは自分のことしか考えてないんだと
赤ちゃんの時も自分のことしか考えなかったと
幼稚園の時も自分のことしか考えなかったと
自分には何か欲しいければ甘い顔を見せただけですよと
でも自分が何かやってほしいと頼んだら嫌な顔をしたんじゃないかとお使いでも頼んだら嫌ですよと言ったんではないかと
だからこの子もやっぱり結局は生まれてから自分のために生きてきたんだから
どうぞ自分のために頑張ってくださいと
一緒にいたら私は殺されますからね
それは嫌ですからね そういうことでせいせいしますよ
例えば人から言われたってもね
あなたの息子さんでしょう
あんなどこかで言って
なんか暴力振るって警察に捕まれてる
あ そう はいはい それで終わるですね
あ 大変だとか何とかとはね
もう家出しましたからね
自分で自分の道を開けるそうとか
じゃあ勝手にしてください
だから私が行って言うと
また私も追い出されるし
それはまた嫌でしょうし
家に戻ろう 戻る 戻りなさい
戻れと言っても 向こうは嫌でしょうしね
戻ってきたっても こちらはもう全然性格直ろうともしないでしょうしね
だからもうすごくクールな心で
冷静な心で生きていられるんですよ
だから この自分を探すということは
まあそういうことから始めるんですよ
自己愛というものがあって
我々は生きているんだと
だから本来みんなわがままだと
ポイントは一つなんですけど
まあまあ それで ちょっと一休みしますか
じゃあちょっと五分休憩いたします
あの仏教について この初期仏教について
まあよくよくちょっと批判される時ありましてね
まあ個人のことばっかり喋ってるんだと
大衆の救いのことは言ってないんではないかとかね
という話はあるんだけど
やっぱり仏教は今まで説明してた立場で
こんな大衆の救いなんか考える人がいるかと
という疑問があるんですね
本当に我々は他人のために頑張っているんですかね
だから なんでやらなくちゃいけないかという質問をすると
なんで人に親切にしなくちゃいけないんですか？なんで人を助けてあげなくちゃいけないんです
なんで良いことをしなくちゃいけないんですか？とかね
そういうふうに疑問視した方がよく分かりやすいんですね
だから 最初からもうそこら辺で私はアプローチしたんですね
だから この本当の大衆の救いのために
救済のために自分を犠牲にして頑張る人がいるでしょうかと
それでいるならば なんでその人はそんなことをやってるんですかと聞かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
自分を犠牲にまでして人を救う
人を救済するんだと 救ってあげるんだ
なんでそんなことやらなくちゃいけないんですかね
結局自分ではそうやらざるを得ない気持ちにいるんでしょうに
そうやった方が自分にとっては気持ちはしっかりするでしょ
あの絶対的な神様を信じている宗教の世界では
もう神様はもう一生懸命人のことを愛しているんだ
愛してるんだとかね 言ってますけど
神様があなた方を作って育てて面倒見ているんだと
お願いすれば何でもやってくれるんだというふうに言うでしょ
まあ気持ちはいい話なんですが
それでもっとその経典
その宗教の経典なんか読んでみると
やっぱり神様が自分のことを褒めて欲しがるんですよ
自分のことを信じて 悪魔を信じないで
サタンを信じないで 自分の方を自分のことを褒め称えて感謝してほしいと
だからやっぱり仏教の倫理理屈はもうどちらにでも当てはめるんですよ
だから神様は自分の喜びのために大きなお世話と
人間を作った作られた人間にとっては大きなお世話ですけどね
という まあそういうふうな冗談の話は言えるようになってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこの我々はやっぱり自分中心で生きているんです
それはまず認める 認めて
偽善的な世界をやめてもらう
あなたのために あなたのために
あなたのためにということはやめてもらう
やめたところで まあ何か生き方が見えてくるはずなんですね
そこでお釈迦様はどのように自分を守ればよろしいかと
自分を守るということはどういうことかと
自分が幸せになるということはどういうことかと
そこはずっと仏教を通して喋っているんです
だから仏教はベースにすごい個人のことばっかし
個人の悟りばっかり喋ってるというふうに言うのは失礼な言い方で
仏教はただ真理を語っているだけで
ですから この法華経で
ダンマパダでアッタワッガという章一つありますよ
これ章なんですけど あのアッタっていうのは自分という自分という一言葉の経典をいくらかまとめていて
で そこで今までの話からこれは理解できると思いますよ
あの百五十七 見てください
アッターナンチェーピアンジャンニャーラッケイエナンスラッキタンティンナンティンナンアンニャタランヤーマンパティジャッゲイジョパンディト
であまり深い説明には今日はいきません
で アッターナンチェーピアンジャンニャ
自分のことを好きであるならば
自分のことアッターなんてのは自分のこと
チェもしピアン好きやと思うならば
その一言葉なんです 今まで説明したのは
みんな忘れてるんです
自分が好きなのは自分のことだと
自分が大事にするのは自分のことだと
それを忘れているんです
それは悪いことじゃないんで
しょうがないんですよ
これはしょうがないとずっと今 １時間かけて説明してたんです
それをまず思い出してください
だからそれからお釈迦様は説法するんです
だから 君が君のことを好きだと思うならば
ラッケイやナンスラッキタンラッケ守りなさい
それを自分のことをスラッキタンものすごくよく
しっかり守りなさいよと自分のことを
そこでティンナンアンニャタランヤーマン
ヤーマンというのはこのピリオド時間なんですね
人間にはつのピリオドがあるんです
ティンナンというのはつ
つの時間がありますね
その中で一つだけでもアンニャタラン一つだけでもパティチャッゲイエ
頑張りなさいと パティチャッゲイっていうのは
あの いわゆるこの何ていうか
手入れしたり洗ったり
もういろんなことを修理したりとか
この直すことなんですね
だから一般的には自分のことを好きで好きだと思うならば
自分を大事に守りなさいよ
人生のこのつの時間の間で
一つだけでもいいんだから
しっかりしなさいよと
それで人生の日数っていうのは
若い時と中年の時と老年の時なんですね
だから若い時はふさげていい加減な生き方をしたならば
もうしょうがない 過去だから
だったら中年の時頑張ってくださいと
中年のバカでふさげて自己破壊に頑張ったならば
老後 老後の時でも守りなさいと
だから人生つに分けて
一は失敗したらから頑張る
は失敗したらで頑張るということで
とにかく頑張りなさいと
早くも自分を磨きなさいよということなんですね
スリ158 アッターナメーバパタマンパティルーペーニニセーアタンニャマヌサーセイヤナキリッセイヤパンディト
まあこれとこと関係ない話なんですけど
一応見たら意味がわかると思いますね
アッターナンエーワパタマンパタマン
最初に自分で自分のことをパティルーペーニニセー正しく戒めなさいよと
何よりも先に自分のことを戒めなさいよと
自分正しなさいよと アッタンアニャマヌサイ
それから他人に言ってもいいんだよと
他人に説教する前 説教するのは後の話で
他人にいちいちうるさく説教する前にアッターナメーワパタマンファースト
最初に自分のことを正しく正して綺麗にしなさいよ
それから他人にも教えてあげる
そうだったらな キリッセイヤパンディト
その人は怒れることは汚れることはないんだと
批判されることもないんだと
だって自分がしっかりしているんだから
自分がしっかり生活をしているんだだから人にも言えるんですよ
自分もだらしないのに
他人に何であんただらしないんですか？って言っちゃったら
結局批判買うだけでしょうね
アッターナンチェタタカイラヤタンニャマヌサーサティ
スダントーワタダンメータダメータアッターヒキラドゥッダモ
そこでアッターナンテーチェタタカイラ
自分でやりなさい ヤッターアニャンアヌサーサティ
あなたが他人にいちいち指をさして言うでしょ
あれやれ これやれ しっかりしなさい
真面目に勉強しなと それ人に言うことは自分でやりなさい
人に言うんじゃなく 自分でやれと
だからわかりやすく言えば
自分が他人に言うごとく自分でやってみなさいよ
なぜかというと 人間のこの偽善的な生き方
お釈迦様はもう全くもう見えているんだから
お釈迦様には よく見たら世の中の人々はみんな他人に説法しているでしょうに
嘘をつくなよ 盗むなよとかね
自分のことは全くもう関係ないことにする
世の中を見てください
偉い有名な人々なんかはね
もうどんな国でも偉そうなことを言うんだけど
他人に対しては真面目に頑張ってくださいとか
本人はどうですかね 言ってる本人は
だからその場合 お釈迦様が他人に言うことをね
自分でまずやってみなさいよ
なぜかというと アッターヒキラドゥッダモ
自分というものは育てるのはなかなか大変難しいんだ
だから人の欠点はよく見えますからね
自分のこと見えないでしょうね
だから人に言いたがるものは本当は自分にあるんですよ
だから自分の心を直してください
これ160   アッターヒアッテノーナートコーヒナートパロシア
アッターヒアッテノーナート
自分の頼り 自分は自分こそが自分の頼りですよと
ナートっていうのはもう頼ること
帰依すること もう神様みたいなもんなんですよ
自分の神様は自分だよと
だから自分の救いは自分だよと
コーヒナートパロシア
他人には何もしてあげることはできませんと
それでちょっと考えてください
我々の救いを他人がやってくれますかね
やってくれないんですよ
みんな自分のことをやってるんですよ
だから それがずっと私は 1時間かけて説明してたんです
お母さんが子供のためにやってるんじゃないんですよ
自分のためにやってるんです
やらなかったら 自分がとんでもない
情けない 空しい 嫌な人間になってしまっちゃうんですね
生きる意味さえもなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからお母ちゃんにおっぱい
赤ちゃんにおっぱいあげてるんですよ
だから自分のためにやってるんですね
ですから 人が私のことを庇ってくれる
助けてくれる 救ってくれる
成仏させてくれると思ったら
これはちょっと計算違いと思いますね
だからみんな自分のことで精一杯だからね
だから自分の頼りは自分しかいません
コーヒナートパロシア
他人は助けてくれませんよと
アッタナーヒスダンテーラナサンラブティドゥッラバン
自分をきちんと整えて戒めたならば
得難い頼りを得られるんだと
ドゥッラバンというのは得難い
珍しい ナータンというのは頼り
支え 救済 救いですよ だから自分をしっかり守りたいでしょうに
この自分のしっかりした守りを
安全性自分を育てると得られるものだよと
で 深い意味に行かないので
さっさっさっといきます
161 アッタナーヒカタンパアッタジャンアッタサンバワンアビサンマッハティドゥンメダンワジランワスママヤンマニ
すごく立派な偈なんですよ
アッタナーヒカタンパアパン
自分で犯した罪 いわゆる自分でやった悪いこと
アッタジャンアッタサンバワン
全部自分から生まれたと
悪いことは自分でしたんだと
人のせいじゃないんです
みんなとにかくこれ社会のせいだ
人のせいだと言うでしょ
悪いことしたっても 子供が万引きしたら
それは親のせいだとかね
環境悪かったんだから
あの子が不良に走ったとかね
よく他人のせいにする
だから あの子供が不良に走らないように
みんな一生懸命人類が綺麗な環境を作ってあげなくちゃいかんですかね
冗談の話じゃないでしょうに
親が仕事で忙しかったんだからと
子供がちょっと精神的におかしくなったと
冗談じゃないでしょうに
だから子供が食いっきりで親の面倒見ちゃって
誰が食わしてくれるんですかね
言い方考え方が間違ってますよ
例えば母親だけで子供を育てるんだったら
母親は仕事をしなくちゃいけないでしょうね
で 子供はもうやっぱり一人ぼっちになるでしょうし
だからといって子供には不良に走る権利がないんですよ
それで社会がやっぱりいろいろ文句を言ったっても
じゃあ母親は仕事を辞めて子供に食いっきりと面倒見る
そうすると社会が食べさせてくれますかね
学校の学費やら出してくれますかね
出してくれないでしょうに
だから何言ってるんですかと
母親しかいない まあ一人親で育てる場合はね
それでその子供が悪くなっちゃったら
みんなやっぱりこれ一人親でしたから悪くなったんだよとかね
母親はもっと子供のこと見るべきでしたよとかね
いうのもちょっとおかしいし
やっぱりまあ子供はしょうがないんですけどね
やっぱりもう頼っちゃいますけど
やっぱりそこら辺はちゃんと理解しておけば
母親は子供をしっかり育てることできますよ
あなたには私しかいないんだよと
あなたは半分頑張ってくれなきゃ
まあ 2人とも終わりやとぐらいはちゃんと納得してもらわないと
子供悪くて なんで私はここまで苦労しているのに
あんたそんなことやってるんですかと
だから 1日学校をやめて一緒に来いと
仕事に 私はどこまで苦労しているかと見なさいよと
そうやって堂々と育てればいいでしょ
そういうこともなくてね
だからアッタナーヒカタンパーパン
アッタジャンアッタサンバワン
自分が悪いことをするんですね
自分悪いことは自分から生まれるんですね
例えば親がかばってくれないということで
自分が悪いことをするでしょう
自分のために何でもやってほしい
やってほしいと言っても
世の中は他人のために誰もやってないんです
それでしつこいになるでしょ
子供も お母さんが 24時間付きっきりで私の面倒だけ見てくれてくれると思っていたのにと
やってくれないんだから
じゃあもう万引きでもするぞと
放火でもするぞというのは冗談じゃないんですけどね
そんな誰も自分のことを見てくれないでしょうし
それは理解してほしいんですよ
たとえ子供でも人は一人だと自分のことしか見ないでしょうと
あなたもそうでしょうと
例えば一人の母親 一人の親の子供だったら悪いことをすると
なんであなたは自分のことしか考えてないでしょうと
だからみんなそうですよと
だから私はあなたのために頑張る必要はないんだと
私も私のことだけこれから考えるんだと言っちゃえばがっかりしますよ
子供はやっぱりこれやばいと
母親にちょっと親切にしてあげないと
母親いうことをしないと
自分にはこんな馬鹿者できませんということがわかるでしょうに
だからみんなお互いに助け合ったりする世界でしょうし
だから結局は自分がまあ大事なんでしょうし
だから悪いことをするのは自分なんですね
そこをわかって それによって自分が行った罪がアビマッタティドゥンメーダ
この愚か者を なんていうんですか
粉々にするんだと だから自分が悪いことするでしょ
自分やった悪いことで自分潰されちゃうんですよ
他人が自分を潰すことがないんです
自分の行為なんです 例えば悪いことをしたんだけど
社会は変な目で見ているんだと
別に社会は関係ないで
自分がやったことだから
自分がそういう風になるだけで
仕事をクビになったとか
会社が悪いでしょうかね
しょうがないでしょうに
だから自分を潰されたんだと
例えがあります ワジランワスママヤンマニン
ダイヤと同じ ダイヤを磨く場合はダイヤの粉を使うんですよ
同じものなんです サンドペーパーでは磨けません
だからあのダイヤとダイヤがぶつかると
そのダイヤ自身が潰れて潰れていくんですよ
そうやって自分の心で現れてくる罪を
自分を壊していくんですね
我々の心に現れてくるこのいろんな悪いことは
自分を壊していくと そこでこの 162 は難しいんですから
163 に出ます スカラーにあさどーに
アッタノアヒターニチャ
ヤンウェーヒタンテサードンチャタンウェーパラマドゥッカラン
スカラーニアサードーニ
悪いことはしやすい いとも簡単にしやすい
アッタノアヒターニチャ
自分のためにならない
自分を破壊する 自分に不幸を招いて招いてくれる
悪いことはいとも簡単にできます
しやすい ヤンウェーヒタンテサージュンテ
何かが自分のためになる
とても良いことであるならば
タンウェーパラマドゥッカラン
それはとても難しいんだと
やりにくいんだと という偈があるんです
それはもう当たり前の原理でしょう
子供には勉強し 勉強しなさいと言ったらえらくやりにくいんですね
遊びなさいと言ったらえらい簡単にやるでしょうに
だから子供のためにどちらがあるんですかね
遊んで 1人前の大人になる人はいないでしょうに
遊んでプロになったと
やっぱり勉強しなくちゃ
何か学ばなくちゃあかんでしょうし
学ぶことは嫌ですね 子供は遊ぶことは好き
そこでやりやすいことばっかりやる
このやりやすいことっていうのは自己破壊なんです
家庭の奥様たちもよくご飯喋ったり
人もやりやすいことばっかりやってるでしょ
あれで自己破壊になっちゃうんです
みんな酒飲んだり 時間を無駄に使ったり
だから大人も子供もみんなやりやすいことばっかりやりたがる
このやりやすいものは自己破壊なんですよ
ですから この本当にいいことっていうのはもうやりにくいんです
なんででしょうかね それほど自分のために頑張る人だったらやりやすいはずでしょうし
偽善だからですよ 偽善だから
もともと 自分が人のために頑張っているんだとえらい誤解しているんだから
やっぱり自分のことを大事にしなくちゃいけないんだと
自分には自分しかいないんだとわかったら
勉強でも何でもするんですよ
難しい仕事でも何でもするんです
難しいとも何も思わない
人のためにやってあげてるんだ
やってあげてるんだと思ったら
やっぱりやりたくないとかね
ご褒美くれとか褒めてくれとか言いたくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この 自分に対して良いことは
人間にとってはやりにくくなっているんだと
でも頑張れと やりにくいと文句言うんじゃなくて
これ自分のためだから良いことをしなさいよというのは
この 163 の教えなんですね
で  165に行きます アッタナーヴェカタンパーパン
アッタナーサンキリッサティ
自分でやった悪いことは自分を汚す
アッタナアカタンパーパン
アッタナーヴィスッチャティ
自分で悪いことしなかったら自分は清らかになる
スッディアスッディパッチャッタ
自分が汚れたものになるか
清らかなものになるかというのは自分次第だと
聖者になるか悪になるかということはあなた次第だよと
何をあんなに必要だよ
他人が自分を救ってくる
清らかにしてくれることはありません
自分次第 人は悟らせてくれません
自分次第だよ  そういうふうなことで
うん あの 一応あの飛ばしたものはちょっと難しいんです
これ 164 もちょっと冗談で説明します
ヨーサーサナンアラハタン
アリアナンダンマジーナ
サーサナンアラハタンというのは
阿羅漢たち悟った人々の教えを
聖者たちの正しい生き方を
いわゆる仏教の世界なんですけどね
お釈迦様はこういうふうに真理
本当のこと みんなもう嫌だ嫌だと思ったってもしょうがないんだ
事実言ってるんだからね
嘘は言ってないんです
ごまかしは言ってないんです
ズバリと本当のことを言ってるんです
お釈迦様は王様でしたから
もうサイケでもね だから人の機嫌を取ろうとは思わないんです
言いたいこと 言いたいことではなくて
言うべきことは言う だから人間というのは他人のために頑張るよ
こんなの嘘やと 偽善で自分のことしか考えてないんだよ
それはもう それは自然な法則だよと言ってるんだからね
そういう教えに対していろいろ言うなら
パティッコセブンメーと頭が悪い人々が
これも否定するブッダの教え
やっぱり救ってもらいたいと
山の神様 川の神様 カエルの神様とかね
それはもう信じて助けてくれとか
そうやってこの安いやりやすい方向へ走りがっちゃうでしょうね
それでパティコ的なのを否定するならば
ディクティンニッサイパーティー頭が悪いんだから
パラニカッタカッセはアッタガータヤパッライ
彼はもうすごいきつい結果得られるんだと
それは自分の破壊になるんだと
やっぱり自分 やっぱりこの論理的にきちんと物事を見ないと
自己破壊にはなるんです
それは別に脅しではなくて事実なんですね
で まあいくらかそうやって
あの お釈迦様はこの自分というものが中心にして
我々には良い人間になりなさいということと教えているんですね
だから 良いことをすれば自分のためになる
悪いことをしたら自分で自分を汚す
だから何一つも他人のためというよりも
やっぱりやった方が自分にはいいんですよ
子供の子供をしっかり育てた方が自分が気持ちいいんですよ
例えばもう 自分がお腹が空いてるんだけど
弁当一つしかない もう一人の人が突然来る
その人もご飯食べてない
それでも自分が食べないでどうぞ食べてくださいと
でもやっぱりそれさえも自分にとってはいいことをしたんだと
気持ちいいんですよ だから良いことをしなさいと
それはすごく気持ちいいし
事実感が生まれてくるし
自分は我ながら捨てたもんじゃないと思えるんですよ
今はもうどう思ったって本当に捨てたもんですからね
だからもうそれはやめて
あの やっぱりそんな捨てたもんじゃないよっていう気持ちがね
現れるように生活した方が
すっごく幸せな生き方が成り立つんです
ただ 極普通に生きていればいいということで
ちょっと考え方だけ綺麗にする
例えば子供が勉強したくないと言ったら
いい 私が嫌だよと 私の子供はまるっきりアホでバカで
腐ったりで怠け者でね
だらしないというと 私はすっごく嫌だなとね
だから私の子供やと思いたくないんだよと
はっきり本当のことを言えば
すぐ聞きますよ 私の師匠はそんな教師なんです
言うこと聞かないと 生徒たちやらね
あんた方はね 死んでも生きててもどうでもいいの
関係ないんだと 勝手にやれと言った途端
もう真面目にやるんです
なんとかと別でしょうと
ただ言っただけやと 勉強しなさいと言わなかったら私が悪いんだからね
言わなかったら悪いんだから
一応言っておきました
やるかやらないか どうぞ勝手にしなさいと
そうやられるとしっかりやるんですよ
しっかりやるとまたこちらまた気分がいいんですね
ああ 頑張ってるんだと
ですから このもう生易しいってはなくて
なんかちょっときつい方がいいんですよ
一応 でもそれもすごく論理的できちんと
やればいいということで
また経典いくつかありますが
また同じ法句経でもこういう風な教えがあります
他人の過ちをいちいち見るなよと
探すなよと 他人が何をしているか
何をしていないんですかとか
そんな他人のことは放っておきなさいよと
アッタナアウェッケイヤ
自分のことを観察しなさいよと
自分がいいことをしているか
いいことをしていないかと
自分のことを観察しなさいよと
人のことを放っておけと
今の前に話すテキストにあったように
やっぱり人のことを見たがるでしょうしね
説教したがるでしょうし
それはあまり仏教は好きな方法じゃないんですね
えらく他人に説教ばっかりすると
ですから やっぱり人のことを置いといて
人のことを気にするんじゃなくて
それすごい情けない生き方なんですね
人のことばっかり気にして気にして自分の生き方を直すと
あれ間違いなんです なぜ間違いかというと
人々が私たちのためにしっかり生きているんですかね
私は何をやるべきか 何をやってはいけないんですかと
それは私に教えられるように生き方していますかね
みんなわがままでしょうに
なんで私たちはわがままの他人に従わなくちゃいけないんですかね
ある人が自分のために
自分が美しく見せるために顔に黒い色を塗っているんだと
あ やっぱり私もやらなくちゃいけないんだと思うの
何でしょうかね あれは
人がお化粧するのも おしゃれするのも
その人の勝手であって
私のためにやっているわけじゃないんですね
私がそれを見て猿真似をして自己破壊になる必要ないんです
みんな遊んでいるんだから
私も遊ばなくちゃいけないんだと
みんな酒飲んでるんだから
私も酒飲まなくちゃいけないんだと
なんでそう思うんですかね
だから他人の目を気にするということは
もう無知そのものなんです
決して他人が私の幸せを願って
私の道徳を道徳正しい人間になることを願って頑張っているんですかね
誰も 誰もそんなことやってないでしょうね
だから人が何やってるか
何やってないかってのは
そんなことはどうでもいいんです
自分の心を観察して 自分が清らかな人間になるんだよということは
ブッダの教えなんですね
そこで人間というのは
自分のことは好きであることさえもわからなくて
逆に自分のためやと思って悪いことばかりしているんだと
チャランティバーラドゥンネダアミッテーネーワアッテナ
本当は人間の生き方は自分を愛している生き方じゃないんです
我々の生き方が どう言えばいいんでしょうかね
自分の敵なんですね 自分自身に敵のごとく生きているんです
敵のごとくじゃない 敵として生きているんですね
だから逆に言えば あなたの敵は誰ですか？自分です
私の敵は私なんです 私は好き勝手に生きているんだから
全部自己破壊になっちゃうんで
だから誰のせいでもなくて
自分の敵は自分なんですね
それ愚か者の生き方で
だからお釈迦様はそれはやめてくださいと
自分のために生きてみなさいよと
なんで自分を敵に回すんですか？例えば嘘を言ったり
人のものを盗んだり 怠けたり
嫉妬したり 憎しんだりするでしょうに
あれで誰が負けるんですかね
人を憎しんだり 嫉妬したりすると
誰が幸せですかね 自分でしょうに
不幸になるのも 憎しみと怒りを持って生活すると自己破壊になるのは自分でしょうに
相手には関係ないんだから
我々は人のことを嫉妬する
例えば その人が本当にもうと思ったりしてね
嫉妬して嫉妬していると
その人は知らないでしょうしね
嫉妬されているんだと
嫉妬する側がどんどんどんどん壊れていくでしょうに
だから自分の敵は自分なんです
平気で人のことを憎む
憎まれた側にとっては別にどうったことないんです
あの人に憎まれてるんで
じゃああっち行きましょうと
別れればいいんだからね
でも人を憎んだ人がずっとその憎しみで壊れていくんですよ
ですから 人間というのは自分を敵に回してるんですね
そこをもうやめなさいというのがお釈迦様の言葉なんですね
それからもう一つ偈がありまして
後で後悔することになるものはやるなよと
何かやる前に これで後悔することになるでしょうかとね
ちょっとでも疑いがあるんだったら
やらん方がいいんですよ
誰かが甘い話をしてきて
大久保さん 今頃この株買っちゃえばね
2週間でも10倍儲かるぞとかね
で それで写真まで持ってきて
何々家の何々さんがこうやってもう今はこういうふうな家に住んでるんだ
こういう人はこういうふうに住んでるんだとかね
で 5,000万借金もあって
もう株買ってもう半年間で全部払いましたよとか出てくるでしょうね
その場合はちょっと気をつけた方がいいんですね
だから後で後悔したっても
もう遅いんですよ ですから
そういうことだけではなくて
嘘をついたり 人を殺したり
生命を殺したり 悪いことをしたりして
ああ 悪いことをしなかった方がよかったなと思うのは馬鹿馬鹿らしいんですよ
勉強しておけばよかったなとかね
今更 旦那に逃げられたら
やっぱり私はちょっとキスすぎかったね
もうちょっと親切にした方がよかったと
もう遅いんですよ ですから
この後で後悔するようなことはもうするなよと
ですから 毎日毎日ちょっと気をつけて生き方をする
ちょっと疑いがあったら
これちょっとわからないなと思ったら
すぐそれはやめる ということで
気をつけて生きてみなさいよと
それからこの頭が悪い人々が何か教えたっても
これまたとんでもないことになるんだ
ということは みんなこの自分のことを大事にしなくちゃいけないんだということはわかってないんですね
それで何か教えるでしょうに
教えたらそれまた逆に行っちゃうんですよ
例えば宗教の世界でもそうあるんですね
例えば この宗教でよくある話で
この布施をしなさいと寄付なんかはしなさいよと
それは悪いことじゃないんですよ
それでおろか者っていうのは
もう自分ものすごいわがままでね
悪いことだけ考える人々でしょ
それでその言葉だけ書いて
とことん搾取したり 社会に迷惑をかけたり
人をいじめたりまでする
それは宗教の例を出す方がいいと思いますけど
例えばこのもう真面目に
信仰して頑張りましょうというふうな話やるんだけど
それは別にいいことなんですけど
じゃあ信仰しない人はどうしますかと
いて その人を潰しちゃうんですね
じゃあ神様を信じない人々は
神は否定してるんだから生きる権利はないんだと言って
じゃあ殺してやるぞと
いて 人殺しにまで行く
それで現在まで世の中で
歴史の中で そうやって慈しみを語りながら人殺しをする
神の愛を語りながら戦争をする
ということはあったでしょうに
今もあるでしょうに あれは愚か者なんですよ
だから良い話は愚か者に教えても危険
危険なんです 違う例で言えば
例えば性格できてない人々は科学とか勉強するでしょう
恐ろしい人々がね 小さい時からもうそう恐ろしくて
でも頭はいいんですね
中勉強する 勉強して科学者になったら人類破壊するものばっかり作る
だから何のためにその科学知識必要でしょうかね
今 自然丸ごと破壊して
我々の細胞の中 ＤＮＡ
まで壊れていくんですよ
空気も水もすべて何から何まで
その上 どうやってたくさんの人が簡単に殺されるかと
それしか考えていないという世界でしょうし
だからそんな科学必要ですかね
それよりはもう山の中でなんとかね
植えて なんとか食べて生活した方がもっと立派でしょうに
野生の動物と一緒に何も破壊しませんだから
ですから 知識はいいやと言ったっても
やはり心が汚い人にとっては知識も危ないんですね
自己破壊に持っていくんですよ
時々すごい頭の鋭い人々が
ものすごく鋭くて 銀行のコンピュータープログラムまでできるんですよ
あまりにも頭が良くて
そこでいろいろカラカラしたりして
銀行のお金を盗むとかね
もうハッカーでいろんなコンピューターにアクセスしてデータを全部盗んだりして
それをまた誰かに売ったりとかね
それ自己破壊になるでしょうに
だからそういう人々のあのノウハウっていうのは何の役にも立たないんですね
だからお釈迦様がやっぱりこの
知識さえも自己破壊になるんだと
だからしっかりした方がいいんですよ
自分を本当に愛した方がいいんですよ
自分のこと 自分のことを真剣に守った方がいいんですね
自分を守ったら もうどんな問題も起きないはずなんです
それでもう一つ偈がありまして
アッターハウェイジタンセイヨ
自分に勝つことこそ素晴らしいんだと
ヤーチャーヤンイタラーパジャ
この世の中で一番優れている勝利というのは自分に勝つことだと
だから自分の心を次にやりますけど
安らかにすること 落ち着いてもらうこと
感情にならないこと 怒り
憎しみで負けないこと
それで自己管理できることこそが自分に勝つことなんですね
それは人に勝つよりも優れているんだと
それこそ勝利だと だから自分のことを愛して
本当に自分の感情で汚れないようにして
自分を守る 怒りたい 怒りたい状態なんですけど
怒らないようにする 嫉妬する条件なんで
嫉妬しないようにすると
そういうふうに自分をきちんと管理しちゃうと
その人こそ本当の勝利者で
本当の勇者なんですよ
また あの またあるところでお釈迦様はこうおっしゃるんですよ
頭が良ければね ほんのちょっと
ほんのちょっとでも自分を磨けと
だからいきなり一時一日で完璧な人間になるということは無理ですよ
ですから あの アヌブッベーナメーダーで順番でコツコツと自分の心を磨いてみなさいよと
トーカトーカンカネーカネー
少し少し その瞬間で その瞬間で少し少し自分を磨いて
自分を綺麗にしなさいよ
例えがあります カンマーロラジタッセはニッダメーマラマっての
昔はこの金掘るでしょ
あれは土ですからね 金も銀も別にもうこのアクセサリーみたいにピカピカ光って輝いているわけじゃないんです
そこでまあ金脈ですか
言って あの 何て言いますか
その土をね 何て言いますか
あれは 採掘なんて品物を何て言いますか
鉱石 とにかく石やら土やらを混ぜているんだから
そういうものはまず石ですよ
ほとんどね それを持ってきて
それを砕いて まだ金がないんですよ
まず砕くとかね それからいろんな方法でも洗ったり溶かしてみたりとかね
いろいろやってみて それでも綺麗な金じゃないんですよ
それからまあいろんな過程を経ていて
ゆっくりゆっくりゆっくり純金の塊作っちゃうんですね
だから １トンの土を採掘したかもしれませんだけど
最後には １０グラムぐらいの金でもね
得られますからね それが価値があるんですよ
そんな感じで 自分の心もゆっくりゆっくりいろんな過程を経て
綺麗にして綺麗にして頑張ってくださいと
だから穴を掘って じゃあ私は純金掘るぞと思って
これちょっとありえない話で
それはありえないんですよ
もうダイヤ宝石の場合も
そんな過程はない それでももう掘って選んで調べて
原石を取らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だから大量の石の中で
ほんのちょっとのダイヤやら宝石やら見つからないと
トラックごとに持ってくるんで
持ってきて洗って洗って洗って
すごい根気の必要な仕事なんです
石の中で同じ石 他の石と同じ色なんですね
その中で見つけて それでもまだ役に立たない
それからもう割れ目が入ってるんだったら
それは破って これは分けて
それから光を当ててみて
それから磨いて それでも何千万年の何千万円の価値の宝石になるんだから
そうやって根気よく まあゆっくりと自分を磨けっていうことはそうあります
まあ言えばたくさん経典ありますけど
キリがないんです  そういうことで
まあ一応長い時間喋りましたけど
この無我のアイデンティティとかね
そこら辺には一応入りたくないんです
で まあ簡単にね 言えば私がよく知ってるのは誰のこと？ ...誰のことですかね
自分のことでしょうに
私がよく知ってるのは私のことでしょうに
だから人がお腹が空いてるかじゃないかっていうことよりも
しっかり自分がお腹が空いてるかしないかで
それはしっかりしているし
時々人がお腹が空いてるような顔をしていたっても
聞いてみたらお腹が空いてない可能性もあるし
だから人が頭が痛い 頭が痛いと言ってわからないでしょうに
そんなものは どんな風な痛みかと
だから自分の頭が痛いと痛いとで
それはわかりますよ それは人もわからない
自分のことは だから私たちははっきり知っているのは自分のことでしょうに
それ以上何もないし だからもう余計なうっさいことを考えないで自分を磨けと
他人に説教しないで 神様に頼らないで
おてんと様に頼らないで
どうか救ってくださいとかね
私を清めたまえとかね
のんびりやっているわけじゃないんだけど
神様は だから自分の不幸を自分でやらうと
自分の汚れは自分で落とすと
私の歯が汚いのはあなたのせいだと言ったらおかしいでしょうに
これは自分が歯が磨いてないんだからでしょうに
ですから やっぱりこの自分がよく知っているのは自分のこと
ですから 宗教っていうのは自分を磨くことなんです
それには他人を対象にしない
あの人のように磨くということは
あんまりちょっと当てにならないんです
別にその人々は我々のためにしっかり生きてくれるわけじゃないんだからね
だからどの人のようにといえば
お釈迦様のように お釈迦様の弟子たちのようにとやった方がいいんです
その方々はちゃんと完全に悟り開いて
もう完璧になって落ち着いているんです
いたんです 落ち着いて
そこでモデルにするならば
ブッダか悟り開いたお釈迦様の弟子たちだけなんです
でも その方々も別に我々に見せるために演技をやったわけじゃないんです
自分の心の苦しみをなくすために修行しただけなんです
お釈迦様も自分で輪廻の輪廻転生の苦しみから脱出するために
真理を探し求めていって悟り開いたんです
一旦もうやる仕事終わったんだから
みんなに教えてあげただけで
ですから この隣の奥さんのようにしっかりしたいとかね
どっかの国の誰かのようにやりたいというと
ちょっとね 気をつけた方がいいんですよ
なぜかというと いろいろテキストあるでしょ
何々さんのお話とかね
ナポレオンのお話とかね
それからまあ クレオパトラ
日本語の発音わかりません
もうクレオパトラの話とかね
ああいう風になりたいとか
誰が知ってるんだよ クレオパトラか
黒人ですか？白人ですか？かっこ悪い人間ですか？綺麗知らんでしょうに
だって国によって美学違うでしょうし
どこかに国がありますよ
女の人っていうのは ドラム缶のようにものすごくまるまる太った方がぶよんぶよん状態がすごい綺麗だと
でも日本だったら歩く骸骨で骸骨って言うんですか
え？の方が綺麗やと だからこの美学っていうのはやっぱりそのその国によって違うでしょうし
それまた時代によっても違うでしょうしね
ね 若い人を見てもね もうその年
その年って美学は変わるでしょうに
ですから あの人のようにしっかりしたいと思うのはちょっと心配ですよ
裏はわからないでしょ
ナポレオンが本当に立派な人か
とんでもない恐ろしいとかわかりますかね
大体は歴史っていうのは嘘ですよ
すごく膨らまして書くんです
事実そうじゃないんです
そういうことだからね
まあできるだけ時々立派な小説
すごいびっくりするほどの感動
超感動するほどもの方々いるでしょ
個人的な人格は無茶苦茶な
だからその人のようになりたいと思ったっても
どういう風になるんですかね
むちゃくちゃな生き方をすることで
だからあんまりこの他っていうのはね
あまりもうね ちょっと心配ですよ
大体人間っていうのはすごく苦労するポイントはそれなんですよ
人のこととにかく気になる
学校に行ったら成績表やらもう隣のことやら
そればっかし気になる
幼稚園に行ったら お母さんたちが次の他のお母さんたちのおしゃれやら帽子やらそればっかし気になると
まあ生き地獄作っちゃうんですね
例えば ある奥さんがものすごい綺麗な服を着て
立派な格好でいたっても
家の中はどうかわからないでしょうに
おそらくもう旦那は全然家に戻らないで
そこで腹が立ってお金無茶苦茶使っておしゃれしているかもしれませんしね
それで外から見た奥さんが
あの あの人の旦那がいいですね
いっぱいお金あげて もう綺麗でおしゃれでとかね
羨ましかったっても裏がわからないでしょうに
私もそういう風におしゃれしなくちゃいけないんだと思ったってもね
それはわからない 例えば逆に髪の毛も乱れて
服もボロボロで あっちこっちもうもういい加減な奥さんを見たら
誰かあのおっかさんが本当にかわいそうやと
ろくな服も着ない着ないんだと
ボロボロだし いたってもわからないでしょ
裏のことは もしかすると
元気で明るくて 子供たちとしょっちゅうふざけて遊んだりして
もうもう子供たちにいくらおしゃれしたっても意味がないんだから
今はやめたと というふうな
もう喜びで満足でそういる可能性もあるし
別に髪の毛おしゃれする必要ないんだとかね
愛されているんだと 子供たちにも旦那さんにも
これは私はしっかり頑張っているんだからということだったら
別におしゃれなんかいらないでしょうしね
だからやっぱり見た目ではわからないんですよ
ですから そういうふうな人をモデルにするということは
それほど知識的じゃないんですね
だからモデルはないんです
モデルは仏法僧だけで
仏教の世界だから 私は
ブッダとブッダの教えとブッダの弟子たちはモデルなんですけど
まあそこ他はまあそこそこでいいんじゃないんですかね
ですから やっぱり自分が自分の心を知っている
自分が怒るか怒らないか
嫉妬するかしないかとかね
それは知るためにお釈迦様は教えて教えてあるし
そこら辺見て自分をちゃんと磨いてみると
というそこでまあ頑張ってください
まあ難しいところしか残ってないんだから
そこら辺で話を終了いたします